Norman did a morning interview in
Cleveland one of those wake up good
morning I watched it it is [ __ ]
hilarious
it was great actually would you look up
mark Normand Cleveland Morning Show
maybe would would it be on YouTube mark
yeah it's on YouTube I started I think
on your maybe your Instagram yeah that's
right you sent it to Stan you robbed
yeah this is very very funny mark
Normand he did one of those TV morning
shows yeah I do these once a week I'm
always hungover
no nobody sees it but this one helped
because it kind of went viral but it
only went viral in Cleveland okay now
you very attractive interviewer go I was
really working it you are yeah it seemed
like you were trying to charm her yeah
cuz usually there's some old dusty broad
who doesn't care but she actually seemed
kind of into it she was going with it so
I was like I might have a shot here
you know who's fantastic at these isn't
Tom Segura the gourd is the rapper yeah
he's a DJ DJ DJ dad mouth that's it and
Tom Segura likes to go on these and I
think we've watched it together Jim he
likes to go on these shows in full
costume and not promote the gig and say
yeah the gig is happening but it's
really more about the after-party DJing
then he makes up a venue for the
after-party great he you gotta figure
out something they're so brutal they're
so phony and undestand genuis it's
horrific but you can look this up and
we'll tweet it out it's called mark
Normand on new day Cleveland will tweet
out the link at Jim and Sam show so you
can watch the video along fast bad
questions yeah well they don't know what
to ask right they don't I mean they
don't know who you are they ask a lot of
times they'll go into your Wikipedia yes
and they'll say I hope they're not doing
that for JD in the straight shot why
there are very terrible reviews about
yeah their wiki not fair not fair all
the cheap shot but yeah they asked you
yes I was born in Bayonne and they'll
ask me about that oh yeah numbers last
time you're in Bayonne I mean when I
fell on my mom's wanted because you
moved right away right yeah what was
Bayonne like how would I remember do I
remember yeah who cares nothing to do
with who I am comedy what was your
childhood like you started suckin dick
at 5 what are you gonna say exactly
right
it was great salad days let's see this
this is mark Normand in Cleveland doing
a morning show we need comedian mark
Normand in our lives so be here at
hilarities this weekend so welcome here
into the studio it's good just right
away like this set up for this is
already so flawed because the audience
that watches a morning show like this
yeah their idea of let's have a laugh is
not the product that you supply mark no
like the stuff that you do on a comedy
stage right is not what the people who
watch these morning shows think of when
they go oh I just want to go and have a
laugh or the people who paid for tickets
exactly it's it's some old bag with a
with a knitting needle there or
something she doesn't care about yeah
your demo is not watching this yes
exactly the best thing you could
possibly do is [ __ ] on this interview
yes right completely that's all I have
in me I'm I got nothing to the tank I'm
on two hours of sleep I'm in Cleveland I
hate myself I'm selling no tickets so
all that is a cauldron stirring to this
it's rough isn't when you know there's
like you got to push the fray yeah yeah
yeah owner of the club is giving me [ __ ]
like that's good look at the light this
weekend just saying we could have had
mark curry but we picked your ass and
it's austere Cooper did he say that's
you know you a little light oh yeah I
get that all the time like Tammy pest
Catelli cleaned up last week just saying
we know we got you in a nice hotel I'm
like it's a holiday Express but then
yeah you can't turn down you can't say I
don't want to do the morning shows
unless you're selling a ton of ticket
exactly and it's in the contract so it's
part of it you have to do it so welcome
here into the studio it's good to have
pleasure I don't know what I don't know
what to say I think it's like talking to
your mom's friends yeah the best is your
casual cross legs they put your hands
uncomfortably on your dumb knee you can
listen to the cameraman laugh it's
delayed he's a little gay so out of
place right it's like where do we go
from here we can just say sabotage the
beginning from the interview from the
beginning it's your own interview
those cameraman laughing that keeps you
going a little bit you know the thing
with these these interviews and they
want you even if you are selling tickets
they want you to do them cuz you're
still getting the club's name mentioned
so they want it in there either way so
you get to a place where you're really
just trying to pop the cameraman pretty
much yeah cuz it just gives you a
glimmer of hope like oh that is actually
funny because these women they don't
they're not laughing at you
know there's a live studio audience I
always bomb in front of them because
they're morning they're like a but but
they're nice they're never nasty they're
always like to smiling if the audience
wants you to be good so now therefore
you know your material they're not there
for that I flop you're behind some
[ __ ] you know disabled kids choir
there's always some nice community
things happening look at that they're
raising money for polio oh how sweet
and then they're like so what do you do
er and my [ __ ] [ __ ] I terrible at
these yes the world like if you went on
Ellen that crowd is so happy-go-lucky of
rainbows sunshine but I want to do a
scissoring joke because she's a lesbian
right but that's not gonna fly and
they're gonna go you suck I mean you
can't even do your intro where you say
I'm a little gay on Ellen no because
that Alan wants to take it in a whole
direction that's a good point you can't
do it you're you're right off the map
from the beginning out of the gate here
with you she's gonna ignore that she's
gonna roll right past that cuz she dies
2019 she did maybe he's a gay comic I
don't know saying that you know why you
would have said that like there's no
context for that whatsoever but the
irony is in these PC climate homos
whatever if I say gay they get weird but
maybe I am a little gay like right you
don't know shouldn't that not be a
controversial thing if you are it
depends if you're saying it just for
humor value controversial if you are
indeed a little bit gay yeah then I
think that that's not sure if you're
just saying it out loud when you're
alone and wondering well there's a
problem with you saying you're a little
bit gay but gay isn't the problem you
say in the word a little bit yeah that's
the issue not homosexual
[Laughter]
I'm saying I used to have a joke of my
act about gay marriage and I did a clean
show like whoa oh you can't do that I'm
like the joke oh it was about how I
don't care about anybody which helps you
with gay marriage cuz you look like a
hero
like oh I don't care so it's not even a
controversial thing it's not even a
controversial taste a mention of the
word gay marriage in the humorous
content exam they go hey well that's not
clean you're like well isn't that
offensive what you're doing
absolutely have you said gay marriage is
on the list of dirty words it's very
offensive offensive you're holding them
down you're saying that it's like it's
like saying [ __ ] or something right
right I thought we were normalizing
hiding my erection yeah I know you just
loves Lyman's yeah that's Lyman's so I'm
best corned beef and in the Midwest if
you ask me it's delicious they ate the
size of your head yeah yeah and I ain't
way to much but that's at least
everybody there was very a trick help
down a miscarriage joke there don't say
the miscarriage she is beautiful
beautiful Wow I can't even look at it
you get on her she's married oh that's
right they always are yeah I love
Cleveland girls oh yeah Cleveland girls
are [ __ ] sexy man bear and they're
humble that's why they live in clawsome
yeah their best and they're rated
there's a lot of radio fans in Cleveland
yep Cleveland girls are the best and so
in Boston girls now they probably didn't
want you to make a Doody joke about
their local food isn't like them when
you immediately said yep I went there
I'm gonna pee on the toilet later as
probably she's probably out she's blue
my fire yeah I'm not trying to I just
want to mention how big the food is
that's all I'm trying to have a good
time yeah exactly
all right let's rewind a little bit rum
but I ate a pound of corned beef at 6:00
in the morning you know it's not good oh
yeah I mean you're not lying now wasn't
ideal so I'm really gonna be on the
toilet later but boy best corned beef
and in the Midwest if you ask me it's
delicious they ate the size of your head
yeah yeah and I ate way too much but
there's anybody there was very
attractive
no I'm kidding she wanted to go with it
like oh we're just being nice they're
not attractive yes it's pork people it's
corned beef folk good good good grub
there I've been flirtin it up in the
green yeah exactly he would just try to
be polite and we called hotboxing really
soaking it all in is the smell of your
own farts for some reason is enjoyable
if you farted weird are you trying to go
into kind of like a fart wholesome but
they don't want it they don't want fart
talk in the morning no and I can see the
fart stuff isn't working with her so
what I'll take a left turn okay okay
this is good and you already had to
sacrifice your miscarriage yes yes um
this one's for me I see
so Kunal and isn't the smell of your own
farts for some reason is enjoyable if
you farted to be weird but if I fart I
enjoy I don't know what a god thing
maybe I would hear no woman would ever
say something like that no comedian I
would [ __ ] love her farts yeah yeah I
know I was thinking that too you can sit
on my face anytime but here comes the
rewind a bit Rob because I heard I heard
the first sound of a word and I said
there's no way he's gonna say this word
on in the morning show I had nothing
Wendling so I had to come up with a
really nice little left hook all right I
don't know maybe you could hear no woman
would ever say something like that
no more maybe a Qui thing
so you'd give it up on keeping it clean
at this point yeah I don't think
anybody's ever said queefing no I'm new
date no no any morning show it's like a
poker game right now I'm like all right
I'm just gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna call
even though I have nothing right and so
I'm just gonna see where we're at here
she's here in your head you're going
okay she doesn't like the fart stuff
maybe we should go queef yeah or say
something like that no maybe a queefing
[Music]
you live in New York with them like
you're really happy with yourself that
you got your queefing joke yeah and then
followed it up with your probably on
meth relax I'm fine yeah we're all
adults here honey now he feels it all
right the queef joke worked yeah you've
settled in yes it's true but usually at
this point they're like okay we gotta
wrap this up good job they're like put
your door cut short oh yeah Portland I'm
not allowed to do radio or in a TV and
why not I did a Jew joke in the guy
who's this guy we're good we're gonna
took his mic oh but he left really yeah
live on TV live on TV and the guys all
my friends go what you do in Portland
I'm at the TV station they what they're
talking about you still and I did like a
year ago that's amazing so I've banned
myself from there and it worked out
that's I don't think that's on they cut
that yeah they wouldn't have allowed
that on yeah I'm the Internet they've
erased that yeah I said well something
he's like well who could hate blah blah
blah I was like well some people ate
Jews who can hate them and they were
like wow something of that nature wasn't
even offensive my mind right still I get
where they'd want to stay away from
engine hating Jews yes I mean you know
oh sorry
you know you've up you had your coffee
who knows what so yeah we're all adults
here
you live in New York City now but you're
from New Orleans yeah well well done you
ready Grindr bye but she's almost like
she puts her hands down in exhaustion
like I can't I can't do this [ __ ] I know
what Grindr is yeah but now this woman
doesn't know what to do because as the
host of new day Cleveland you can't
admit the Union even knowing what Grindr
is is an issue right you can do that
uh-huh right profile yeah so it's kind
of its continuity is there is here you
live in New York City now but you're
from New Orleans yeah Wow well done you
wanna grind here by looking you up yes
but I I know that that we're talking
about we were talking about Cleveland
sports here but I know for you guys and
your saints that was brutal we really
thought we had it you know New Orleans
all we do is drink and go to this part
up not oh we really needed this win this
is a series you know but no dice right
they're so close
yeah it killed me to get a joke in there
that no she didn't leave you much room
so the Saints lost yeah yeah but she's
really and you actually answered so she
goes okay I gotta keep talking now cuz
we actually this is what I wanted to do
realize that I got these Betty she got
you she got me there she got she's very
good and it killed me I hated this
moment right
that was an 18 seconds of boring to me
right so close yeah always next year yes
one of these every you know century and
that was our shot so when you live in
New York now though so yeah being in New
York City and is it true that did you
just recently move in with a lovely lady
I bought a place I got a little a moved
in with a lady in Alexa yeah she's uh
she keeps track of everything and she
gets mad when I talked to Siri doing by
in your area
I do think that on some level though you
slid into that because she said you
moved in with a lovely lady and you
wanted to be like I'm trying to hit on
this broad right here
I'm gonna do the Alexa joke because we
don't need to bring up we don't need to
bring up girlfriend stuff right now
we're in Cleveland you know me too well
yeah that's a beautiful break down there
everything and she gets mad when I talk
to Siri oh but he did but yeah yeah Bob
my place I own a piece of the rock in
Manhattan it's the only thing my parents
have been proud of that I've done I've
done The Tonight Show Conan Colbert
Comedy Central but when I bought my
apartment that's when they actually
started answering my phone calls but hey
that's why I'm a comedian cuz I gotta
get love somewhere touching her shoulder
he grabbed her shoulder I gotta get love
somewhere he just reaches out like it's
an uncomfortable amount of room I mean
it literally is way too far there's
literally a person's the length of room
between the two of them and Mark just
reaches out and it's his entire arm
length he just squeezes her shoulders
reads you over a person to touch ya
couldn't be less organic there's no
place for that in this conversation but
also the chemistry between the woman and
mark Normand is non-existent but she's
rolling with it pretty well she's great
she's not an [ __ ] she's very good
yeah beautiful phone calls but hey
that's why I'm a comedian cuz I gotta
get love somewhere that was a gamble
yeah in Cleveland that flies that
wouldn't fly in LA or New York no me too
Jay would be yeah me too
all right and by the way the face on the
other news anchor it like she's going
kind of yeah a little bit yeah kind of
is what's her name uh all right
so but for you big I mean you're young
so getting into this business
she didn't want to hear that now she
want to hear black don't crack ready for
that one
no no no no so you could maybe get away
with being a little bit gay right but
you're a white guy you know yeah yeah
[Laughter]
yeah you got her back yes not on the
viagra yet and he gives a a mr. Rob mr.
Roper smile puts his thumbs up oh yeah
which is a lie
yeah best drug ever great drug rather
than chemo what do you think what the
battery five amazing yeah that's great I
love a good blue - I've taken a few
thirty minutes later your dick is in
great shape
yep yep it gives it like a half an inch
it feels like yeah blue choose one
really yeah I got to finally try it try
the blue choose really good or mi who
knows I like to snort it I was I was
feel like I was rolling and I had some
you know we're now we're in a dick
material I could go all day but right
that's she was smart to wrap it there
yeah she was yeah rapido you're through
Saturday yes please okay so we they're
through Saturday if you have a sense of
humor like this you want to get down you
want to enjoy some more comedy from him
go see him foods great
yeah food is good she go Pickwick she
did did she really did we sold out both
show centre that's a big room yeah it
was cuz of this that's awesome yeah so
it's the only time radio or TV has
helped me yeah yeah it's right on that
weird strip but if you go past that
you're gonna get killed
yeah
it's a weird yeah we'll be fine thank
you for coming hey thank you thank you
for coming
so we won shake she proposed me yeah
with the ice pry a handsome guy
good-looking guy didn't he it was like a
weatherman look yeah he like kind of put
her hands out as if to like say this is
the segment and then mark went in for
the handshake she wasn't trying to shake
your hand
no oh she wasn't no no no she was not
that's very very clear look at your arms
out like that and dirty right yeah watch
this yeah she didn't want to shake your
hand
that's pretty good saying I'll call you
later
one more Jim and Sam catch up with full
episodes and interviews from celebrity
guests anytime on demand using the
Sirius XM app
[Music]